you know what my number one government  regulation concern is about crypto i'll  tell you what it is that there is no  government regulation we can't really  grow this industry until it gets  regulated and we have the rules let me  give you an analogy you know you love  football i do i like to watch it on  sundays you can't play football if  there's no rules you got a bunch of guys  running around the field that don't know  what they're doing because they don't  know what the rules are same with crypto  we need the rules that's the regulator  once we get the regulator on board we  all understand the rules we can all  build this industry up because the  potential is massive